welcome back the former Chelsea player
and manager jean-luca viali has died
aged 58 after being diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer for a second time the
Italian who was first diagnosed five
years ago played for and managed the
London Club scoring 40 goals in 88 games
between 1996 and 1999. he went on to
lead the blues to win several major
trophies including the FA Cup and the
League Cup well joining me now is Dan
silver a board member of the Chelsea
supporters trust who saw the Ali both
play and manage the team a very good
morning to you could I firstly get your
reaction to the news yes charity sad
news and vrd was a massive icon for
Chelsea he was a foundation of the
modern Chelsea Glenn huddle came in and
we had root alert then Vianney came in
and just that whole Italian trauma magic
he really kind of brought you know the
modern Chelsea you know he's just a real
icon loved by everybody and first goal
against Coventry City the pure joined
his face as he celebrated he was just he
was up by everybody not just by Chelsea
fans I think the whole football
Community is a huge loss for for Chelsea
and for football
he set a world record transfer fee um
back in the 90s I think when he went to
Juventus for uh 12 and a half million
pounds it's hard to believe it now but
he was clearly at the very top of his
game nationally and internationally what
do you remember of his strengths as a
player I was just he was great within
cup player he scored goals he knew where
to she shot early just a real real great
modern football to play one of the best
of his generation I think he could score
with his head he could score his left
foot he was just a real joy to watch and
he played with a passion he absolutely
loved the game every time he scored the
pure joy
um I remember you know a very iconic
even Chelsea's history was in 97 FA Cup
game against Liverpool with two more
down at half time and the second half he
scored two goals we won four two we went
on to win the FA Cup that year which is
our first trophy since 1971. so really
so many great memories of violi you know
the chance to be early VR they ringing
around Stanford Bridge just you know a
real Charming Man not just a great
person but a great football as well
yeah I was going to ask you about his
time as manager because he had success
didn't he before it then turned a bit
sour on him yeah I think I think this
could be a Chelsea thing you know he did
be what he wanted he won trophies and
then we start the season badly and then
obviously the the old ownership decided
to bring in a new manager but he was
always loved everything about him that
the way he held himself I mean there was
a classic uh pitch where he was having a
tough time when Chelsea scored a goal
and Dennis wise lifted up his shirt to
say you know cheer up Luke and we love
you I think he he was like by everybody
you know fantastic manager at the time I
created a manager with the trophies even
you know after Chelsea he came back
regularly you know he always just fell
in love with Chelsea we all fell in love
with him yeah I was just going to say
you've talked quite a lot about how
popular he was what was it about him you
think that made him so popular not just
as a teammate but also a manager and
amongst the fans I think I think Chelsea
signed a global Superstar but he was
almost like he was one of us he
teleported the whole culture of Chelsea
Football Club you know the Italian
generation like a dimateo we had we've
heard of her master desk so I've had all
the all these fantastic Superstars but
he was the one who really who really got
the club what we're about you know when
he lifted the FA Cup as a manager he saw
how much he meant to him when he got the
Cameo appearance in the 97 Cup final he
won two nil just it was just one of
these cookies couldn't have not failed
to fall in love with it's a real a real
gen a real real wonderful human being is
a really sad day for us for us all yeah
I was just going to ask how are Chelsea
supporters going to honor him
it's hard time no matter that that kind
of we achieve us I think when we play
our next home match against Crystal
Palace on San Diego should there be a
really great you know minute size for
municipals you know you know maybe I
know it's very all quite raw maybe you
know name a standoff to impossibly just
see just a real a real icon you know the
perfume of great Chelsea managers and
players is going to definitely always be
up there
for Chelsea
all right uh well it's been an honor
speaking to you uh Dan on what must be a
very sad day uh for you and all of
Chelsea supporters thank you for your
time thank you